good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight if you lived in this
country 15 years ago and you've got a
good memory you may remember the
creation of something called the
national security division at the
department of justice it was created
back in 2005 when they re-upped the
patriot act now the point of the
national security division we were told
at the time was to conduct
counter-terrorism and counter-espionage
operations against foreign adversaries
this was the big stuff mostly it was
islamic terror which was the primary
threat of that time but these are also
the people in charge of busting chinese
spies who are trying to steal our
nuclear secrets stopping suicide bombers
and hijackings not small stuff
crimes that threaten the nation
that was then
then joe biden became president in
january and the entire mission
of the united states government changed
and turned inward
against you
a few days ago the department of justice
under the radical attorney general
merrick garland announced that the
national security division has a new
domestic mission
according to garland effective
immediately the national security
division is handling the investigation
of quote harassment intimidation and
threats of violence against school board
members teachers and workers in our
nation's public schools end quote
so the question is who is threatening
these teachers and school board members
is it al qaeda
is it the russian government is it isis
k no
it's parents
parents are angry about what's happening
in schools why are they angry well take
a closer look at the people joe biden
has nominated to senior leadership
positions the department of education
take a look at youtube videos while they
still exist of some of the school board
meetings across the country over the
past year and you will know exactly why
parents are mad
parents who believe in things like
biological sex who oppose racial
hierarchies imposed in pre-kindergarten
classrooms
teaching kids to hate their parents
those are the threat according to the
biden administration
you'll notice if you look closely that
nowhere in merrick garland's recent
order or the doj's press release is any
explanation of these quote threats of
violence
what threats of violence has violence
occurred at school board meetings
no
look closer and you'll find this line
quote the justice department will also
create specialized training and guidance
that will help school board members
understand the type of behavior that
constitutes threats oh
so it's a propaganda operation funded by
you out of the department of so-called
justice designed to tell teachers and
school board members that when parents
complain
it's domestic terrorism it's not the
first amendment in progress it's not
your constituents voicing legitimate
complaints
it's effectively a foreign adversary
trying to kill you
the bide administration is trying to
convince school board members using the
department of justice that they are in
physical danger from parents and those
parents are national security threats
once again nothing like this has ever
happened in this country this is an
utter perversion of the mission and the
power of the united states department of
justice
it is almost impossible to overstate how
sinister and crazy this is
we almost never play the equivalence
game because it's tiresome but in this
case it's hard to resist
imagine if donald trump's doj designated
say cnn anchors as domestic terrorists
put it in writing and then told men with
guns to enforce the law how would that
go over
we for one would be outraged by that all
decent americans would and it would in
fact be less of a stretch than this
order
a lot of cnn anchors made excuses for
violence during the riots last year
but the media aren't upset about this
when powerless suburban parents resist
having nihilistic ruling class
ideologies imposed by force on their
children our media seem to believe it is
perfectly fine to designate them
terrorists and threaten them with
firearms in a version of america where
school board meetings have become the
new culture war battlegrounds with
children caught in the crosshairs
sometimes literally and sometimes
figuratively right now everyone from the
proud voice to the oath keepers to q and
on influencers are trying to encourage
their their members their followers
their maniacs to show up at school board
hearings some behavior is so bad it's
being compared to domestic terrorism
this becomes a security crisis in a
sense for the nation how one republican
senator is pretending school board
harassment and intimidation aren't off
the charts similar tactics to what
happened on january 6th that now are
being turned against school boards
nationwide in a trend that's really
disturbing and sinister conservatives
manufactured outrage over masks and
history lessons took our school boards
hostage like a bunch of screaming
maniacs
so the federal government has a
designated american parents who are
unhappy with the education their
children are receiving as domestic
terrorists and the media are defending
it
this is so shameful it's hard to
describe the entire point of a free
press is to protect the weak from the
strong
but as usual and more flagrantly every
day our media does exactly the opposite
they slobber over billionaires they
defend the powerful they call you a
bigot if you challenge george soros and
on the other hand they clap like seals
as working-class people go to jail for
thought crimes
they're trying to pretend that's not
what they're doing that they're not
sucking up to power that they're not the
praetorian guard for the biden
administration but they are
they're telling you this is about
domestic terrorism they're repeating
merrick garland's own words there's
nothing with freedom of speech
on msnbc this week the daughter of the
united states senator that would be
robert menendez of new jersey one of the
biden administration's closest allies in
the senate promised that she would air
definitive proof that parents who dare
to challenge the orthodoxies of the joe
biden administration are in fact a grave
threat to national security
she would show us proof that the
national security division needs to
investigate these parents treat them
like criminals for daring to speak up at
their own school board meetings before
members of the school board they elected
to run schools they pay for that educate
their
children here's the evidence she
presented
frank i want to play some more sound of
these school board meetings so we can
get a sense of just how out of control
some of them are getting take a listen
don't put masks on our kids anymore
because i'm telling you what i'm a mom
who's fearless and i will come after you
you're allowing child abuse you're
allowing child abuse you're allowing
child abuse you're allowing child abuse
suffering things have become so scary at
these meetings that the organization
representing school boards across the
country is asking the federal government
to help arguing that the classification
of these actions could be the equivalent
to a form of domestic terrorism
so mothers stand up before a school
board which is their constitutional
right in fact their duty as parents
to say that they believe based on a lot
of scientific evidence that their
children are being hurt by a policy that
makes no sense
imagine looking at that tape and blaming
the moms
and suggesting that their behavior is
quote scary and they're terrorists and
the fbi should show up at their house
and hassle them like their al-qaeda or
isis k assuming that even exists
what do they say don't put mass on our
kids anymore it's child abuse well
actually that's true and anyone who's
looked at the data knows that it's true
belgian pediatricians for example in the
belgian academy for medicine not a third
world country just issued this
assessment of masks in school here it is
quote
testing children imposing mouth masks
and quarantines go against the principle
of first do no harm which is included in
the hippocratic oath that doctors took
these drastic actions do much more
damage to the children in the short and
long term than going through the covet
infection itself
end quote
now that's not some angry mom from
laguna beach those are physicians saying
that and if you look around and you
should you will not find a single
scientific study anywhere in the world
that fundamentally contradicts that
assessment there is no science none
behind these mask mandates for children
in fact just days ago joe biden
secretary of education miguel cardona
tried to cite his study to back the
administration's forced masking of
children which is a total outrage and
when he used this study to justify a
political decision the senior author of
the study tracy hogue said cardona had
no idea what he was talking about and it
completely misrepresented her research
which by the way had no control group so
by definition doesn't prove anything
but don't bother
don't even bother getting rational on
this subject if you dare to cite
scientific conclusions
you are a domestic extremist and the
media will demand that you be
investigated by the fbi
and they're justifying this in exactly
the same way that the chinese government
explained away murders it committed in
tiananmen square
they're accusing people who have been
completely wronged by the government of
undermining domestic stability by
complaining about it
what used to be called legitimate civic
disagreement
is now a threat to the nation
is this really about people being upset
about mass mandates or are there sort of
underlying disruptive forces white
nationalists
anarchists whatever in this country that
are using mass mandates and a public
health crisis to sort of wait uh wage
chaos
get that [ __ ] off television that's
hurting the country i mean come on now
they're racist now
they're racist because they don't want
their kids to be masked
imagine saying something like that
there are underlying forces at work
secret forces you can't see
must be q anon or white supremacists
there are no organized white supremacist
forces in this country we have a lot of
problems that's not one of them
the point is we don't like their
politics therefore they don't deserve
civil liberties that's what they're
saying that's what they believe
you have to wonder if any of these
people have ever seen a school board
meeting or if they're just repeating
what they're told it's not the parents
who were causing chaos they didn't start
this they had
a totally ordinary and justified
expectation that their kids would be
educated as kids have been educated in
this country for more than 100 years in
public schools
the schools themselves changed
and parents solely woke up to this fact
their kids are being taught racism in
schools they're being hurt what the hell
are you doing
so parents go to meetings to voice
objections to teachers who are
advocating racial segregation and book
burning and they're doing it on camera
they're not doing it in secret they're
not plotting this isn't the q and army
these are just normal americans
here's tate from virginia back in may
it's funny how they are so afraid of
their children seeing another view
of sexuality gender or religion if you
want to talk about books that are
assigned let's read to kill a
mockingbird together
if you aren't willing to consider the
racial trauma this assigned book
causes black children with its white
saver
saviorism
then you have no business discussing any
books
well exactly
if you're telling kids that dr seuss and
to kill a mockingbird both of which are
explicitly anti-racist and were before
that was even a term thought up by some
grifter at boston university
if you really believe that you're a
lunatic and let's just say that out loud
you're a lunatic
and if you're complaining about it
you're not the one waging chaos
look around on cable news and you won't
find anybody explaining what's actually
going on
instead you'll find people like nicole
wallace barking about how people who
don't agree with her don't deserve civil
liberties
we almost never use her name on the air
nicole wallace is the physical
embodiment of virtually everything
that's wrong with this country she is in
a word loathsome but let's be completely
honest if the federal government ever
decided and then declared publicly that
nicole wallace was a terrorist for her
political opinions we would
unhesitatingly leap to her defense with
maximum vehemence we would do it
instantly and we wouldn't stop
because we believe in civil liberties
would she do the same for us of course
not if the entire staff of this show was
arrested tomorrow for our beliefs nicole
wallace would celebrate and that's the
difference we believe in civil liberties
and they don't
how can you tell has nicole wallace or
anyone else at msnbc said a single word
about the federal government spying on
people's google searches that's
happening
accidentally the feds just unsealed
court documents showing that the doj
under joe biden has been obtaining
sensitive private information from any
american who typed in certain keywords
into a google search
a minnesota judge for example recently
approved a secret warrant requiring
google to provide tracking information
on quote
any user within the city of edina
minnesota who searched a fraud victim's
name
oh
is it a stretch to think that this could
be extended to ideological crimes which
are the crimes the bide administration
really cares about no it's not a stretch
at all in fact of course it's happening
and no one on television even mentions
it because they think you deserve it
because they don't think you have civil
liberties because they don't believe in
god therefore they don't think you got
those rights from god they thought you
got them from the government and they
could be taken away because you've been
naughty
and so they applaud when they're taken
away
google collects an awful lot of tracking
information on its users including their
names home addresses browsing history
going back decades
so that's a story you would expect a lot
of people on the left would be concerned
about if it was 20 years ago they would
be the aclu would be all over it
it's proof once again the government has
too much surveillance power over
american citizens and they are abusing
this to spy on americans who've done
nothing wrong but not one of the
national security experts so called an
msnbc or cnn will even mention it why is
that
because their job isn't to protect you
or civil liberties but to protect the
party in power
that could be why they're not telling
you anything about marilyn garland's
personal stake the attorney general's
personal stake in persecuting people who
challenge the insanity we're seeing in
school boards across the country it
turns out merrick garland's daughter is
married to a man who is the co-founder
of an education service company called
panorama education which you will not be
surprised to learn provides materials on
critical race theory to school districts
including dismantling quote unconscious
bias and systemic racism in schools
oh
so the thing that parents are
complaining about
is the thing that merrick garland's
family is getting rich from
two days ago merrick garland just made
it a crime to complain about the beliefs
that are enriching his family does that
make sense you should know that this
specific company has raised a ton of
money for mark zuckerberg's foundation
fairfax county public schools just
signed a 1.8 million dollar contract
with panorama to conduct a multi-year
social and emotional learning screener
that gives them the right to collect
quote psychometrics on the school
district students
do you realize they're collecting
psychometrics on your kids what is a
psychometric anyway this is insane
some of the questions ask whether
students are quote sad or quote gender
fluid
it's all making merrick garland's family
rich this is horrifying it's also
potentially legal
according to the doj's own conflict of
interest policy it raises serious
ethical issues but of course it does the
doj rules require employees to seek
official guidance before quote
participating in any matter in which his
or her impartiality could be questioned
oh
that would include situations in which
matters can quote affect the financial
interests of a relative with whom the
doj employee has a close relationship
that probably includes your daughter
merrick garland did you do that
you can be assured that no one at the
doj's national security division is
investigating that question tonight
instead they're promising to go after
people
to designate people like elena fishbein
domestic terrorist hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else